how goes it everybody I'm red Muffler
Man so the anime for chainsaw man
finally aired its first episode and uh
holy [ __ ] this episode was dense and
today I'd like to go over any of the
small details you might have missed my
thoughts on this first episode what made
it so unique as well as where I think
the anime will be going in the future so
let's get into it the first thing I'd
like to talk about is the opening it's
so pretty Studio mappa you can't keep
getting away with this so one thing
Studio map has shown on shows like
Attack on Titan and Jujutsu kaisen is
the studio isn't afraid to go all out
sometimes to the detriment of their
staff the op is chock full of references
to Landmark films and I'm not talking
casual Winks but painstakingly remade
Sean for shot Recreations from films
like No Country for Old Men The Big
Lebowski Jacob's Ladder Pulp Fiction
Texas Chainsaw Massacre Constantine the
list goes on and on and you can see the
appreciation for each of these shots
they even go to the point of matching
the aspect ratios of the films they're
referencing which is pretty sick to a
video editing nerd like me not to
mention Fujimoto himself the mangaka is
a huge film buff and has a ton of
references to other movies present in
the original manga so this is literally
just a further extension of that love
letter to film but going into the
animation itself one moment you'll have
denji flying through the air scaling
down buildings only to get slammed into
those same buildings in which each cut
individually spell out the letters CSM
you have the gang going to the movies
eating bowling dancing it gives this
feeling of playfulness while also
hinting in between some of the darker
elements that really give the show its
identity and I think that's rad we even
get to catch glimpses of some future
plot points such as the future devil the
katana man the ghost devil and of course
deji and power doing the Mickey Mouse
Playhouse dance epic I'm begging you put
these little gremlins in fortnite let
denji hit the gritty you cowards but
getting into the show itself after the
joy of seeing denji daydream about
knocking over some bowling pins we're
introduced to the harsh reality that
denji's life sucks this is sold
exceptionally well by the characters
surprisingly grounded performances
giving some real weight Behind These
scenes along with Studio mapa's dark and
Moody visual design and kensuke ushio's
incredible score and then we get to my
favorite part of this episode and that's
animation of the first big battle we
reached the point where dengius first
transformed into chainsaw man and
despite a little bit of funky CGI here
and there this scene whips the fight is
incredible and has a real sense of
weight to it you just don't get in the
manga and the manga fights always felt
fast and frenetic making sure to pay
close attention to the lead up and
follow-through of motions and while this
is true in the anime as well Mamba goes
out of their way to show just how heavy
denji is and oh man it adds so much and
it's so satisfying to just see denji
fight bite literally throwing his entire
body into it with this animalistic Flair
it really lends a feel of physicality
and motion that you just can't get from
the manga this combined with mapa's
Stellar camera work and you have a fight
that is absolutely phenomenal as denji
parkours through a field of zombies
bobbing and weaving giving the camera
this feeling that it almost can't keep
up all in all the first episode was fine
phenomenal and I think honestly we're
looking at something really special here
with the show I'd tell you to go watch
it but I actually already have a video
telling you why I think you should go
watch it and you can find a link to that
in the pinned comment below but the last
thing I'd like to touch on is how far I
think this first core of the show will
be going in terms of what we saw in the
op it's looking like the first 13
episodes will be running from the
introduction Arc likely up until the
katana Man Arc so chapter one up through
about chapter 39 meaning we're gonna get
to see some real good [ __ ] in my opinion
the katana Man Arc is where the series
really starts to cement an identity for
itself and honestly it makes me
incredibly excited to see where the
series will be going from here but yeah
that's enough rambling anime as usual if
you like what we do feel free to like
comment and hit that subscribe button
and if you like me you can follow me on
Twitch Twitter and YouTube at Red
Mufflerman and uh yeah have a good one
everybody take it easy